hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are recording
another episode of good gaming news
which is a weekly ish gaming news show
where I talk about positive news and
gaming things I feel positively about
because there is enough negativity on
the internet not saying a lot of that's
not justified I just don't feel the need
to add to it let's add some positivity
to the world so not a lot of news this
week just in general kind of a quiet
week but I did technically miss out on
this last week so I thought that we
would uh catch up on it here which is
Need for Speed Unbound has finally been
revealed and it looks very different and
they're not wrong this is the official
reveal trailer to show a little bit of
it in case you missed it
um which I didn't even expect it came
out of nowhere
obviously
very stylish
[Music]
it looks very very cool
and I do feel like they needed to do
something to change up need to speed at
least a little bit
let's do it
it's like
like spite of ours kind of Vibes I don't
know I think it looks awesome
um I used to love Need for Speed and
then really really fell off so happy to
see it come back in a kind of different
flavor
um but IGN actually has a little bit
more information than just the uh that
trailer and I think a little bit of
gameplay that's been uploaded so this is
by cat Bailey on IGN it says a new Need
for Speed will be arriving on
PlayStation 5 Xbox series X slash S and
PC this December featuring The Return of
Criterion as the lead developer for the
first time in close to a decade titled
Need for Speed Unbound criterions
long-awaited return to the racing scene
will utilize new gen consoles and the
frostbite engine to deliver 4K 60fps
visuals in a free roaming open world
called Lakeshore got some official
screenshots here it's like hard to
believe that this is a game what a it's
such a cool idea I'm very into it very
very unique looking yeah I imagine that
you can turn all of that off
um because that could be an
accessibility issue for some players
like definitely only very distracting
for certain people but I'm a fan and I
want to play it
uh the article goes on to say in
development since at least 2020 Need for
Speed Unbound checks up many of the
items on fan wish list from previous
years in addition to putting a firm
focus on street racing Need for Speed
Unbound will include an offline single
player mode and cross play though not
cross progression it will continue to
put an emphasis on the cause themselves
meaning a cop pick viewers out but hood
and bumper cameras are in I don't like a
cockpit mode but that's a bummer for
probably a bunch of people and the
interim being since Criterion has
actually worked on Need for Speed the
series is generally languished in the 70
overall range on Metacritic which of
course is terrible 7 out of 10 dog [ __ ]
the worst score you can get way worse
than one through six
I often like a game that's a solid seven
to be honest sometimes playing a solid
seven is just a nice way to tune out
just zone out of what else is going on
in your life I think there's room in the
industry for a seven but Need for Speed
definitely was above a seven back in the
day so if their goal is to like actually
try to innovate and push it out of that
sphere which I don't think a lot of the
more recent entries have done at all if
anything they went in like a direction I
really didn't like though I guess that's
not consistent like I think Pro Street
which is an older game
it was terrible I thought pro street was
very bad obviously Most Wanted an
underground are just right up there and
underground too there are a lot more
Need for Speed games than you think
there are in taking the reins back from
Ghost Games Criterion is keeping the
focus squarely on the areas it considers
to be the series's strengths but also
expanding and reworking many aspects of
the gameplay if I was to boil everything
up to what we're trying to do here we
are trying to make the player feel like
an illicit Street racer and make crazy
bets like an illicit Street racer and
feel the highs and lows of and thrills
of what it means to kind of embody that
fantasy it will also include what
Criterion describes as an immersive
narrative in which two friends are torn
apart by a robbery at a family auto shop
leaving the player to try and reclaim a
Priceless car by winning the ultimate
street race every single one of those
characters we've actually made them full
characters this time Kermit says they've
got little story arcs they've got
personalities they've got their own car
customization and style you can see them
driving around
listen that's pretty standard but I
really do want to highlight something
that I don't find company at all
something about saying little story Ox
why didn't you just say they've got Ox
what's a little story arc he said it
like it's a cute throwaway like you've
got a little story arcs why have you
already made it sound bad
that element extends into side bets
which will allow players to Target
individual characters that's kind of
cool cops of course will be on the
present in Need for Speed Unbound but
criterion's approach will be much more
tactical this time around individual
Vehicles will have their own
strengthened weaknesses which players
will be able to exploit during chases
neat there were definitely uh games as
this article kind of highlights in the
series where I felt like the cops were
actually just extremely annoying and not
at all fun
um it seems like they're trying to
address this by giving players the
chance to deliberately decide how much
cop heat they take on the mechanic that
governs how aggressive the police will
be given at any time Criterion is also
including a police scanner and a
spotting mechanic giving players
additional options for avoiding police
if they so desire multiplayer has been
tuned to be as low friction as possible
when you go into the multiplayer mode
you can drive around the world meet up
with friends or just mess around
probably pretty similar to Forts I would
imagine gameplay customization will also
include thousands of thousands thousands
of thousands you mean thousand Den
thousands thousands of thousands that
might even be the the right phrase and
I'm just so tired right now thousands of
thousands that each
am I insane is that how you say that
phrase who knows Grandma's wasn't able
to say how many cars would be in the new
release only to say that it will have a
lot uh Need for Speed aims to be as
accessible as possible by a driver
assist mechanics while maintaining a
high skill ceiling that's awesome love
to hear that highlighted uh in this kind
of early press coverage so yeah then
they go on to talk about the art which
of course is very noticeable it
definitely does Stand Out they've got
this world is your canvas Gameplay
trailer here
foreign
it looks very cool
yo that's awesome
oh my God that's so cool
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's such a cool idea
oh
yeah it looks rad and I I just feel like
it's um
yeah really good like unique step to
take for for Need for Speed love it love
it there's gonna be so many cool
screenshots out of this just like the
street artists who creatively subvert
the cityscapes around them you'll be
able to tag the world and leave everyone
in your dust tags come to life when you
deploy your boosting powers that makes
it extra satisfying that you've like
customized those and people will be like
falling behind you and you know what
they're seeing that's a really cool idea
boosting powers are earned through
actions like drifting jumps and
near-misses and appear as dramatic
customizable effects that paint the
surrounding world including illustrative
lines that etch around the curves of
your car I love it yeah very into it
Story number two is that valve listing
confirms it's planning to ship a new VR
headset and I feel like it's about time
if you know much about me you'll know
that I am a very big fan of VR I use my
Oculus very frequently sorry my meta I
use it all the time I love it
um and valve I think did a great job of
like spearheading a lot of uh the most
appealing advancements I just I continue
to want to see the industry be iterated
on even if I recognize that that it's
unlikely that biot is going to become
mainstream if it was ever going to
become mainstream it probably would have
happened during the pandemic yes that's
when I started using it all the time
that's when I started working out in it
and I do really highly recommend it but
the reality is just that so many people
like playing video games on their couch
with their living room around them with
their family around them
um I'm now less convinced that that VR
will become mainstream for gaming though
I do still think that if it's going to
take off in an industry it's Fitness
which it I guess has or education I
think there's a really good opportunity
for a lot of um different educational
institutions to utilize VR either for
classrooms or for practice I did speak
to people in the medical field about
using VR and they kind of already do so
but there's potential there but in any
case this is from uploadvr.com and it
says Val posted a job listing to
prototype ship and support a VR headset
with Advanced tracking features at valve
we are pushing the boundaries of virtual
reality experiences we are looking for
versatile self-directed software
engineers in computer vision who can
help us achieve the next steps in VR
with millions of customers worldwide the
main scope of this position is to
prototype ship and support consumer
gaming products leveraging visual
inertial tracking hmd and controllers
camera pass through environment
understanding eye tracking and hand
tracking that's my Andrew Wilson the CEO
of EA I think you'll find I do an
incredible impression valve index the
companies 999 dollar tethered PC VR kit
has now been on the market for more than
three years which wow that really did
happen fast it still has Best in Class
tracking and audio quality but it's 1600
by 1440 per eye resolution has been
surpassed by even low-cost headsets like
Quest 2 which is what I actually have
for the record I have the quest 2. and
pico4 and it doesn't support wireless
play though a startup is working on an
adapter the wireless thing is the reason
really that I prefer the quest Rift was
such a good name dude it like upsets me
when I think about it Rift was a really
good name why not matter riff why Quest
whatever dude I don't know what you're
doing over there I guess the metaverse
has legs now I'm happy for you
Zuckerberg legs in video games it's huge
news in May 2021 valve CEO Gabe Newell
referred to making big investments in
new headsets in a talk at a school three
months later about product designer Greg
Kumo was asked by The Verge where the
steam deck's chip could be used in a
standalone VR headset he replied it
would run well in that environment and
said it's very relevant to us and our
future plan a Val pattern filing made
public four months ago might have
revealed the design of decades strap
sorry deck it was the uh the code name
four effectively a sort of leak of the
new headset it didn't concretely reveal
any technical details and to be honest
does look pretty similar to The Quest
new job listing indicates deck it may
have inside out head and controller
tracking eye tracking hand tracking
posture and scene understanding posture
unseen understanding could mean it will
also support mixed reality though it
could also just be an evolution of the
steam VR chaperone safety boundary
system if decade of shipping anytime
soon it could take on a metaquest pro
expect it to be announced tomorrow which
it was the metaquest pro was announced
earlier this week it's weird looking it
just reminds me of a spider I don't know
and I'm happy that both of these
companies are still working on new VR um
the thing with the metaquest pro is I'm
not going to get one because of the
price point it is 1500 US dollars
I do think that's Justified for what it
is it makes sense to me it features like
high-res senses from robust mixed
reality experiences crisp LCD displays
for shop visuals are completely new and
Sleek at design plus eye tracking and
natural facial expressions it's it's
just too much money dude it's just too
much money with how happy I am with my
quest too I just can't justify that no
unless they stop supporting it which I
don't doubt they'll end up doing maybe
they'll start treating you know uh uh
meta Quest like an iPhone something you
have to upgrade more often than that
definitely very happy to see that
industry continue to be iterated on and
to advance it's something that I really
really really really really really enjoy
I mean I just love any like growth in
the games industry any change in
Direction I just think it's super
exciting it's such a [ __ ] cool
industry so yeah it was just announced
you can catch more info on that um I'm
just happy to see the the competition
alive as well both of these being
sort of discussed at the same time just
excited about that industry always will
be last but not least we got some
previews of wild thoughts which if you
haven't seen it let me just pull up the
trailer here we go this is seven minutes
of gameplay we won't watch all of it
this game looks awesome
[Music]
I mean
it looks so cool let me show you a
little bit of combat in here as well
here we go
thank you
I think it looks awesome but I also was
like oh I want to have floaty that
gameplay is going to be like I wasn't
fully solved on it um it's obviously
living in this marriage between like
Monster Hunter and Sakura which is a
genre that I am very cool with us having
more of and the good news is that media
has been giving Hands-On previews uh
they said they're at Monster Hunter Fan
and that they are now pleasantly
intrigued and looking forward to seeing
more when the full game drops in early
2023 which is always a good way to come
out of a preview they call it rich
vibrant and colorful
full of gigantic beasts akin to real
life animals and their bodies have fused
with all manner of Flora because of a
mysterious Evolution that granted them
the power to bend nature to their will
which also sounds cool they sort of is
uh one of them here pretty nuts looking
the article goes on to talk about
basically Monster hunting and how that's
pretty standard but that does say that
you could choose from three different
monsters in the preview build um to
approach in a different order which is
cool
goes on to say what sets wild Hearts
apart from its competitors is the Kara
Curry an ancient form of technology that
allows you to build various structures
that can Aid you in Exploration or
combat
kind of fortnightly for example the most
basic use of karakuri is building crates
that can be stacked on top of each other
to reach high Ledges or act as a barrier
to block monster attacks you can also
interact with karakuri during combat to
perform special attacks depending on the
weapon and what character you use with
it with karakuri crates you can jump off
them to unleash Mighty Airborne attacks
and I believe that's akara Curry there
so it has like a building mechanic
inside of uh the combat Arenas again
even these Monster Hunter style fights
which just sounds very cool a lot of
different like tactical options probably
gives you a lot of different play style
opportunities depending on weapon combo
what animal you're fighting and how
you're using the Kara Curry as well so
you can also use it to set up base camps
which is cool and set up other card
query facilities in your base camps to
help you prepare for future hunts in
this previews I had access to building a
campfire to cook meals so I could get
temporary stat boosts cool gives you
Buffs a washing line to dry out food
ingredients to create certain meals of
Forge where you can craft new gear at a
watchtower that can detect a monster's
location within scanning range that's
awesome and like other hunting games
such as Monster Hunter where base camps
are predetermined spots on the map you
can even use the carquery to place camps
however you want provided you have
materials to craft them with careful
planning you can set up base camps
directly outside a kimono which is the
again the big animal nest and fast
travel between them to save you some
time when pursuing them which definitely
cuts down on probably what I think is
the least exciting part about Monster
Hunter which is getting to and from the
monsters personally I just want to wear
the skin just get me to the monster let
me wear its tail as a dress if you
happen to run out of resources to build
a camp there are other karakuri
creations to help you Traverse the
environment such as springboard zip
lines and more and the best part is any
of the character constructs I feel like
I've said that word so many times camps
crates Etc you make stays on the map
Forever Until you either dismantle it or
a kimono destroys its very distracting
goes on to discuss some kind of
differences in fighting some of the
different bosses that's such a Studio
Ghibli image there how neat different
weapon types here a katana
wagasa is an umbrella weapon which
sounds really neat can you use uh Parry
attacks and count it with a flurry of
ground and aerial-based Tech combos the
bow of course uh two firing modes but it
is literally above a great sword and the
mole which is basically a heavy weapon
Hammer uh in conclusion I wasn't gonna
read that whole article obviously if you
want more detailed info you could go get
that on Windows Central I don't want to
take away the purpose of their job I was
impressed by what I saw of wild Hearts
thus far this early in the game's
development the weapons are satisfying
to use the monsters are challenging and
rewarding to beat and the free form
possibilities of the Kara Curry add
exciting layers of complexity to the
hunting experience I can imagine
spending hours experimenting with the
karaoke to create optimal routes to
chase down monsters and seeing which
karakuri I've been saying it this wrong
the whole time wait no no that's a typo
I was like it's Kaka Curry not Kara
Curry no no that's a typo thank God
contraption synthesizes synergizes the
best with each weapon type I wonder if
it's going to end up being
sort of like an arc type thing like how
detailed can I get with Base building
here is that a fun thing is it an
unmanned Sky type or is it just like
basic
be interested to see that is it for me
today everybody there might not be an
episode of this show next week because
I'm probably not going to be home
um not sure yet we'll see but otherwise
I hope you're having a wonderful day
I'll see you next time bye